♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute, and I'll show you
how Cloud Data Fusion
can help you build
data marts, data warehouses,
and data lakes fast.
Data Fusion is a fully managed,
cloud-native enterprise data
integration service
for ETL developers, data analysts,
and data engineers.
It provides a visual point-and-click
interface to easily design,
deploy, and manage data pipelines.
Data Fusion improves business
IT collaboration by providing
a unified user experience
for data wrangling and pipeline design.
It's powered by the open source
project CDAP,
making it a flexible and portable solution
for hybrid and multi-cloud environments.
Data Fusion offers broad
connectivity options
to on-prem or cloud data
from databases, mainframes, SaaS,
and enterprise applications.
With built-in features around metadata,
Data Fusion helps with governance
by providing insights into pipelines
through end-to-end pipeline lineage.
To get started with Data Fusion,
create an Instance in the Cloud Console
and then head into the UI
to visually wrangle data
and design your pipelines,
as you profile, prepare, blend,
enrich, and transform data.
Finally, deploy and run your pipeline
on automatically provisioned
Dataproc clusters with just a click.
You can also schedule, monitor,
and manage your pipelines.
Next time you're looking to accelerate
the building of data marts,
data warehouses, and data lakes,
take a look at Data Fusion.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/data-fusion
♪ [music] ♪